All right, I think it's safe to say
that most of us wouldn't mind
having our next guest as their Valentine.
He can sing and act and dance,
and he's added author to his repertoire
with his 5th children's book.
Please welcome back
to the show our friend, Taye Diggs.
(audience cheering)
Now, since you were last on the show, you joined TikTok.
(laughs) Yes.
And your videos are getting a lot of attention.
One has just, you know, 11 million views plus.
I have a clip, take a look.
(singing noises)
♪ Jerk, jerk, jerk, jerk, jerk, jerk, jerk, jerk ♪
♪ Everybody look at me jerk ♪
♪ I'm a jerk, you're a jerk, ♪
♪ and everybody's a jerk, jerk, jerk ♪
(audience laughter)
Where did the idea
for this one come or was it just spontaneous?
Did it just burst out of you?
Were you in a mood?
How did this, what's the origin story?
So look, I'm, I'm old, right?
So I work with a bunch of young people.
You know, I have a 13 year old son
and I'm constantly being reminded, you know
of how unhip I am.
So I watched TikTok with my kid
so I can see what what's going on with the young folks.
So I just started to try to make up versions
of what I saw on TikTok myself and we laugh at it.
You know, my son is, is, is always recording me
(audience clapping)
There you go.
But you're also a huge prankster
Is this true?
I enjoy a, a practical joke, yeah.
Back when my baby mama Idina Menzel
back when we were in New York doing Rent,
I left the theater early so I could beat her home
and I hid in her closet and I scared her
so badly that she immediately bursts
into tears and ran out of the apartment.
So it, it doesn't, it doesn't sound funny when I
when I tell it to you right now,
but I laughed in the moment.
(upbeat music)